FLORIDA MAYBE OPENING THINGS UP
REALLY SOON.
JOINING ME NOW WHITE HOUSE
NATIONAL COUNSEL DIRECTOR LARRY
KUDLOW.
ALL RIGHT LARRY PLEASE BREAK TO
DOWN FOR US THESE THREE FAZES
HOW’S IT GOING TO GO?
>> FIRST OF ALL HEALTH AND
SAFETY NUMBER ONE CRITERIA FOR
REOPENING THE ECONOMY.
LIKE COMPLETELY AGREE WE HAVE TO
GET THE ECONOMY GOING AGAIN.
BUT HEALTH AN SAFETY, IT IS
GOING TO BE DATA DRIVEN OKAY.
THAT’S THE ADVICE AND THE
GUIDANCE THAT OUR BESTS DOCTORS
AND SCIENTISTS ARE GOING TO GIVE
TO GOVERNORS AND MAYORS ACROSS
COUNTRY, AND THE BASIC IDEA HERE
IS WE WANT 14-DAY DECLINE WITHIN
14 DAY PERIOD YOU’VE GOT TO SEE
IT DECLINE IN THE VOLUME OF NEW
CASES.
THAT’S KEY.
SO TESTING IS VERY IMPORTANT
SURVEILLANCE TESTING SCREENING,
DIAGNOSTIC TESTING AND, OF
COURSE, BEST PRACTICES GOT TO
THROUGHOUT THIS ENTIRE PROCESS,
RIGHT YOU HAVE SOCIAL DISTANCING
FOR QUITE SOME TIME.
CLEANING YOUR HANDS, WASHING UP,
AND SO FORTH AND SO ON.
SO EACH TIME YOU LOOK AT A
COUNTY OR A STATE OR A CITY
WHATEVER, AND IF THE DOWNWARD
MOVEMENT CONTINUES EVENTUALLY
YOU GO FROM FLATTENING TO
ADJUSTS DOWNWARD TO ABSOLUTE
SUPPRESSION THAT WILL COVER THE
THREE PHASES AND THEN HOPEFULLY
PRAYERFULLY WE’LL ALL GO BACK TO
WORK.
>> ALL RIGHT SO YOU HAVE SCHOOL
ISES OPENING WITH DISTANCING YOU
HAVE RESTAURANTS OPENING WITH
SOME DISTANCING.
MAYBE A TABLE EMPTY IN BETWEEN
SOMETHING ALONG THOSE LINES?
AND THEN I GUESS MAYBE PHASE
THREE YOU DO LARGER GATHERINGS
OR WE TALKING ABOUT CROWDS IN
PHASE THREE LIKE YOU CAN HAVE
PEOPLE WATCHING A BALL GAME?
>> I DON’T TO BE TOO SPECIFIC
IT’S NOT QUITE THAT WAY IT
REALLY DEPENDS ON WHAT A THE
LOCAL AUTHORITIES ARE SAYING AND
DOING.
BUT BASICALLY YOU’RE RIGHT.
THAT’S THE PROGRESSION IF YOU’RE
WELL AND TESTING NEGATIVE SO
FORTH AND IN NUMBERS YOU’RE
GOING TO BE IN GOOD SHAPE SO
FOLK CAN GO BACK TO WORK AND
BACK TO OFFICE BUILDINGS THEY
CAN GO BACK TO THEIR FACTORIES
THEY CAN REOPEN SCHOOLS YES.
CON CONFERENCE CALL WE HAD WITH
ALL OF THE BUSINESS LEADERS, TWO
DAYS AGO, PRESIDENT HERD
COMMISSIONERS OF BASEBALL FOR
EXAMPLE, TALKING ABOUT REOPENING
BALL GAMES.
SO I THINK THAT KEY IS HERE WE
CAN START MAY IS GOING TO BE A
TRANSITION MONTH.
OKAY, AMERICA WILL BE BETTER OFF
SPIRITS WILL RISE, LET’S GET
BACK TO THE BOOMING ECONOMY THAT
WE HAD JUST A COUPLE OF MONTHS
AGO ALL PRESIDENT INCENTIVE ARE
STILL THERE ON TAXES AND
REGULATIONS, BACK IN PLACE --
BASEBALL LARRY.
>> THAT’S WHAT PEOPLE WANT.
>> PLAY SOME BASEBALL JESS
NUMBERS WILL TELL THE STORY --
VERY IMPORTANT PEOPLE WANT TO
GET CONFIDENCE.
PEOPLE HAVE CONFIDENCE WITH THE
NUMBERS, BUT I THINK THIS IS
VERY DOABLE.
CHIN UP JESSE WE’RE COMING BACK
AMERICA WILL COME BACK.
JESSE: HERE WE GO.